this is this is why people watch tekken
this is it
i grip my teeth at these types of games
because if someone's gonna get really
upset ah when when you're mirroring you
against a guy playing your character it
just gets stressful but i can't wait to
see it i'm sure we're gonna see lots of
shenanigans
i mean so this is i mean the thing is
strog isn't it's not like he's just he
is a steve and lars main he plays them
both equally but probably supposed to
steve more often so it's not exactly
like this is just a throwaway i'm just
doing this for the bands type thing like
he knows how to play this character uh
we saw it early with his dominant game
over gallander oh late on the way from
the show with the arts class
and but he gets it this time that's
something we saw him do so well against
glad it was that with punishment we're
gonna see more of that here
1.43 nice the plus frames plus four
that four
mob he has rage so one launch could be
really big for him here especially with
that new racetrack at last time that
first two in season four
oh and you can tell they've got each
other's timing a little bit and and as a
result it's making them back off a
little bit when they would normally go
in
now honestly nice punisher in the art i
don't disagree with uh strokes decision
to switch to lars um you know it was
steve versus lars the first time these
two played and uh
mob did take that so let's just see how
the last goes that's this philosophy
here nice combos when the setup
look all that damage he took away and
this doesn't look like it it is gonna be
his round unless this counter it changes
everything
drops a combo and down one there we go
two of the best players in russia right
now evo online champion and we can
strong the guy who took out everyone
when he first appeared on the scene
many called this to be the last two
players in the tournament not foot
they're not far off being that they've
gone very far one of them will be going
running three
i sent her up there from mob we're gonna
see a lot of anti-last stuff here
because they both know the characters so
well
world war twos are coming out from both
of them now knight we're punished there
by strzok and he gets the combo no too
many downfall ones or breaks to throw in
the middle of the power crash is one
while setting two stroke one more round
to take the first game here and because
this isn't a losers or winners fight we
are back to first to action
he's looking very good right now
that is so hard to have that unlock
ready just in case
you're not whipping this man's face you
can kind of punish that knife minus 14.
oh but the wall messes him up okay
punishes the while 71.
you tried the oblast again there
right nice punishment by morbid just
like that final round first game
fight
i feel like the entire game is going to
go like this because back and forth
punish that good welding
the ark blast is the trade though who
might not get a combo when he does not
back four
thrown out but nice stuck and punish
there from strog i don't know if you
should have turned around because he
won't get the wall he's gonna go for the
same stuff that mob did earlier
oh he stayed up for the racetrack but he
gets counted okay
mob needs to make this count we are
definitely going to the wall stroke's
not going to be a rage no drops the
clock it up screwed it up and this could
really come back to haunt him okay well
barely stays alive this is as close
as it can be right now
i was just gonna say kobe you know that
there are whiffs out there to be caught
still i can see the odd thing just being
let go here and there that if one of
them latches onto it we'll see
even more offense that was really good
oh these two are so strong
yeah i mean these two are def they're
going back and forth you know it's
literally round it's literally round for
round whoever gets the first run is
going to win the game from the way this
is going so
now it's going to be interesting to see
how they adapt to this i wonder what mob
is going to do for a stage pick here
we've seen you think the infinite
beforehand um and one thing about the
infinite stage as well because they're
both even characters is the koreans like
to pick infinite stages because they
like to say this is just pure tekken
like there's no there's no there's no
shenanigans going on there's no walls
getting away this is pure neutral tekken
is where the the the true tekken is
played so it's where they go when they
believe they're just stronger
fundamentally than their opponents so
let's see if that is what uh mob uh that
goes for it's gonna be true it's gonna
be true um it's a true mirror match
right now lars versus lars
you gotta respect that view equally i
think there is a hell of a mind game in
in the wall uh in the war stages that
you kind of miss out on a little bit
with uh the infinites
here we go arctic snowfall snowfall
is up to snowfall in russia as well by
the way
i think it is because i i know this is
what dragon off
um draganov has his story game against
uh master raven here
it looks like it's kind of like siberia
to me
i wouldn't be able to make that
distinction
need to try stroganoff
right down forward sounds like a dirty
thing i don't want to
for whift
i'm back four
just small pokes right now but that oh
that could have been art last attempt
there were no strokes on point with it
today
oh
this is what i mean it's a mirror match
down back four at the same time but
mobile just slightly faster
nice
and mob is going to draw first blood
like i said that infinite stage you're
playing pure neutral tekken right now
what a good read that was in a great
punish as well
both of them just looking to get that
timing of their opponent
nice beacon of catching timing mod does
it there beautifully
wait these two swatch swap colors
it's i'm not even going on color anymore
i'm just going on health bar i i feel
like the first round struggles wearing
the red because
am i losing my mind
four four two
okay i guess the flippy stays down
half the round
oh nice interrupt there from mob
excellent knows the match up like the
back of his hand and he is one run away
from tying this up
so when they played earlier in this
tournament it kind of went a bit like
this by the way it strog did win the
first game mob then when it decisively
back and then won the final game i
wonder if it's going to go like that
again
i wonder if you have to think about
characters which as well as struggle
loses me to go straight to the steve
you thank you steve previously
[Music]
the the the texas showdown right there
mexican standoff time
the best part about it is it did look
like that hot block hit so strong
spacing an awareness to know that it
whipped go for that whiff punish he is
on point right now as he gets around on
the board
[Music]
oh [ __ ] not a great punish yeah it
doesn't have the same with punishment
all right that's straight falling right
now there it is the count of the four
points is gonna be nice damage here for
mob mom seems to have his timing right
now
[Music]
we saw that ladies running through
the harassment with it orbital
nice we've punished again by stroke
though
going for the fancy stuff no doesn't
work out he just misses it now something
mob will do consistently rage drive
spent
maybe not the best use of rage
especially with the time left back very
nice just like that we are all tied up
one two one in the last
mirror match
yeah it didn't really get much juice out
of that rage drive not even a mix for
anything else and the other rage drive i
guess
it doesn't really do much on an infinite
you want to use it at the wall if
there's a wall break um or if you're
just doing it to to win the game so
okay what'd you do if you struggle well
having watched on mob stream when he
played chatrog earlier he did um beat
his steve
uh did come back though and there were
moments when he struggled steve looked
really dominant so it's not a full gone
conclusion it's another lars mirror he
could go to steve and just have faith in
it in his main i think i think he could
go to sleep like you said but he could
also just bring the walls back in play
you saw mob played well like mob's use
of timing and his movement and his whip
punches is amazing on the infinite stage
i thought just bringing the walls back
in place to give him less place to move
harass him down i feel like stroga's
playing a lot better with the walls than
play but steve is always a choice you
know just depends what he finds he is
more comfortable with in the situation
um if i was saying i just bring the
walls back you know it wasn't like it
just it just looked like the infinite
stage is just mob
infinitely more the most confident i've
ever seen the last player on the
infinite
yeah i think he just picks the infinites
by default no matter his opponent he
seems to really like that stage let's
see what he does
he's gone for this steve and he's got
the
oh boy
okay okay that's unfortunate
the luck of the luck of the russian
there because
he gets the infinite stage steve no
not as good as the infinite stage as
well mob likes the infinite stage this
is the best case scenario for mob to end
this stroke has an uphill battle ahead
of him
waiting for his moment
probably will see quite a few down back
fours it's quite useful tool against
steve
crushes those highs
here we go
oh the timing yeah like i said with a
character like steve with the way the
russians like to play it's very timing
movement base the character c works out
so well for them
running through the frames
oh great whip punishment there from mob
that was immediate
stroke just shy of rage as well one of
the worst situations being but there is
steve one of the best ratios in the game
can make this comeback but not with that
time mob already on the board
two rounds away from going through for
mob oh that's the situation where he
would have got more if he was playing
his last oh very nice
bob looking so good right now
[Music]
the thing is if mob does win this he
goes in to get his revenge on the person
who put him into losers bracket
greetings
g-clef cannon so well timed there one
more hit does it nice block by strong
but this comeback is looking almost
impossible especially with outrage
i don't know if you can do this nice
locks it down back three two mob is one
right away from getting into our losers
final over stroke
dog has a mob shaped mountain to climb
is he gonna do it he would need to find
his timing and make sure he punishes
some of these whiffs
he just needs to take this one round at
a time
oh goes for the low
stroke wasn't ready more low is his
peppering with the lows
nice dark
stroke half of the round is gone oh and
great whiff punish there this shouldn't
be dead especially if you
down one three one more here does it the
wow standing two mob takes it two one
over stroke to move into the losers
final
and you have you have to say